welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down a big question about the
boys that is how is black noir still
alive somehow black noir returned manga
given a fatality in season 3 but we've
seen him parading about the season 4
trailer like nothing's happened
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the big few times about
what's going on and giving our thoughts
on why we think he's back now this video
will contain spoilers for the com Mak so
if you don't want what happens in the
show potentially ruined then I recommend
you turn off now I will save that stuff
until the end of the video with a heavy
spoilers warning in full effect though
so you should be safe for now now
without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
boys season
4 okay so firstly we have to look at
what's going on with black noir and how
we last left things land clearly
murdered the character but it's what
happened next that showed there' been a
cover up now this kind of ties into the
events of gen V in which we know that
homelander is going to stand trial that
is for the murder of a starladder at the
end of season 3 but at no point is black
noir's name being mentioned he's being
kept out of the headlines and it's safe
to say the world still thinks he's alive
this is why we catch whoever this is
rocking the same costume and I think it
goes beyond just passing on a mantle
typically when a hero tends to take over
another Hero's Ro they'll get their own
costume to mix things up that's been
seen recently with Captain America and
Sam Wilson with his one being in line
with the Falcon 2 when bookie took over
Captain America he got those sexy black
leather pants and yeah they always kind
of change things up to show their
different characters Plus in the comics
we had several different Soldier Boys
with each one rocking their own unique
design now black noir's costume hasn't
changed and due the lack of news there's
clearly been a cover up I know people
saw the shut of him standing with a
train in the deep and thought that might
be a moment in which they brought the
new member in these drafts were shown
during genv but with Noir they don't
really need to cover things up man wears
a mask and no one seen his face so all
this stuff it's going to be pretty safe
for now now back in our genv finale
video I actually talked about who I
thought would take over the role I gave
the theory that it would be Sam but now
I I don't actually think that that's the
case now I know from the comments on the
trailer breakdown that a lot of you are
saying that too and hey the evidence is
kind of there if you close enough Sam
has a similar sort of power set and
homelander was watching over him during
the Cameron Coleman show the pair even
hallucinate similar sorts of things with
Sam puppets replacing noir's cute little
critters however Nathan Mitchell is
still playing Noir and I don't know if
they do that if it was going to be Sam
instead I think Mitchell might actually
get some lines now and they had to kill
off the old version to bring the new one
in Noir didn't have any lines we knew he
was the silent and strong type and thus
they might have needed a reason for why
he's going to be talking in this season
now there's also something that could
happen if we look at the comics and
that's the fact that Noir could be a
zombie in case you don't know there's
quite a few characters in The Source
material who get killed and then come
back as the undead the way V Works in
death is that it supercharges your
brains and organs and your entire corpse
is then just reanimated you're able to
walk around and murmur but most of the
higher brain function is now completely
gone what F would do is that they take
one of these Heroes parade them around
and then do a big farewell tour they
then make up a lie about how they were
going off to Ms or something or maybe
the DCU and the character would then
never be seen again looking at you
Wonder Woman 1984 post credit scene
looking at you Black Adam post credit
scene looking at you Shazam Mr Mind post
credit scene looking at you Dark Side
look looking at you George cludy dear
wait how much DCU teasers at the end
right how many DCU teasers have they
done that are just going to lead nowhere
bloody hell man anyway we moving on now
that happened most notably in lamp
ligher who was locked up in v tower and
covered in sheet so I think there is
potential that Noir could even be a
zombie and they might be parading him
around to show things are well and good
I think if it was Sam playing him they'd
probably have him in the role and now
likely want to give Nathan Mitchell
something to do so that's Sam in one
Theory but there's another moment in the
trailer that could hint what's going on
now at one point we see a train picking
up a jar which has some strange strange
material in it in our breakdown I
thought this could be the virus that
Newman confiscated from the doctor at
the woods I also said it could be stor
fr's hair with this being the last thing
that remains of her after her demise
before picking it up there is the photo
of her that we can see and that's why I
drew those connections there the boy's
Twitter account actually cleared up that
it's hair and the jaw and yeah yeah it
might might be pubes oh God this is so
bad now whether this belongs to storr a
homelanders another thing entirely but
it could be leaning in with the cloning
from the comics this is the point where
we hit the breakes guys and tell you if
you don't want the comics Ru then turn
the video off now also if you're
enjoying it and want to support the
channel then please consider clicking
the join button to become one of the
boys for 99 cents a month you'll get
early access to some of our breakdowns
along with things like audio versions of
our film analysis asses and a lot more
huge thank you to everyone who's signed
up so far and thanks for making it so I
don't have to get a real job much
appreciated now the cloning idea takes
us into a big reveal in the comics it
turned out that black and noall was
actually a clone of homelander and that
he'd been created for a very specific
reason that was to kill homelander if he
ever went rogue as V needed someone
powerful enough to take him out if it
came to it however being unable to
complete the one thing he'd been created
for had robbed the man of his whole
purpose in life it would be like if your
one purpose in life was to hit the like
button and you didn't slowly you'd go
crazy and black noir then put in place a
plan to send hom me off the deep end
dressing up as him he'd go out and
commit he his acts like eating babies
and watching screen crush videos he then
photograph these moments and send them
to homelander which made him start to
really trip balls man couldn't remember
doing it and he was worried that he'd
gone insane himself however this
eventually emboldened him because he
believed that no one was going to stop
him no matter what thus in the end he
created a soup Uprising and storm the
White House which is where he killed
President Victor Newman which you can
see where that's going mate in the end
the Army arrived and the Final Act was
to send butcher in to stop him black
noir also showed up as well and it was
at this point that we got the reveal
about who he really was now after giving
you an Omnibus worth of story I don't
think that they're actually going to do
this that's purely because Homeland is
selected who the new members of the
seven are and he's clearly wanting
people who are on side man didn't even
mind attacking the Guardians of gulin
and this was because he'd seen they'd
happily fight against other the soups if
it was the right thing to do do in the
past homelanders had issues with the
seven because people like Maven
starlighter have stood up to him in the
end thus the new members are probably
handpicked by him and I'm guessing that
that includes Noir too now again this
may mean that it's Sam as he was
watching him on the news and smirking
away he would be someone that could fit
into the role but then I kind of have to
wonder about what happened with Kate
people would probably ask questions
about where the new new guardians of
gulin went and th I think it might just
be easier to keep things simple and have
him remain as a guardian with the seven
being their own thing there were a ton
of different teams in the comics and
barely any of the members in them made
their way up to being in the ranks of
the seven I think it makes more sense to
have homelanders followers be spread out
on other teams instead of just getting
them all in that one group we need stuff
for season two of gen v as well mate so
yeah best just keeping Sam out of it if
you ask me still though they may be
going the Clone route and potentially
they made someone that can be controlled
by homelander rather than just getting
what happens in the comics honestly
Anything could happen but I kind of feel
the Sam thing might have been teased at
the end of gen V if that is the case now
guess what mate I want you to do some of
the bloody work instead of me let my
throat all cracking on you you better
step in and start pulling your weight
drop a comment below with your best
theory about what's going on and if it
turns out to be right you'll have
evidence you're a genius you're smarter
than heavy spoilers which isn't saying
much but your voice Probably sounds
better as well cuz I've been up all
weekend doing trailer breakdown videos
so thanks uh thanks for all the supp
now if you want to get some heavy
spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located below the video
that will let you pick up all kinds of
tops like our Theory time one house of
dragons stuff Marvel te's and a lot more
we drop new designs on there all the
time too so definitely keep an eye out
for them and you know I'm cutting the ad
sorry my voice is too knocked at this
point but thanks for sitting until the
end it's been a very long weekend I'm
going to go Li down now but as always
your support is massively appreciated
and I hope you enjoy the rest of we made
take care peace